♪ ♪ ♪
ensoleillé, Hugo Bourgoin
s'en va au parc avec sa femmeete
en traîneau ne se termine pas
comme prévu.
HUGO BOU
- Le temps de faire un tour
de parc, d'arrêter jouer
un petit peu, glisser,
on revient et alors qu'on est
encore dans le sentier,
lques secondes de revenir
à la voiture, sous nos yeux,
notre CRV, notre véhicule
s'en va tout tranquillement.
Nous, on avait déjà eu
une tentative de vol sur
l'année passée.
- La Honda CRV est le véhicule
volé au Québec.
Selon le palmarès 2021,
suivent ensuite les camionnettes
Ford de la série F
et la Toyota Highlander.
JEAN-CLAUDE GRAVEL,
président, Groupe Gravel
- Le véhicule est victime de
son succès. Plus le véhicule
est vendit
des pièces ou être revendu
dans un autre pays
les voitures et les camions SUV
les plus populaires sont ceux
qui sont le plus volés.
- Les concessionnaires
automobiles ne sont pas
à l'abri. Gravel Honda
est victime de vols dans
son propre stationnement
sont prêtés en courtoisie,
ce qui fait bondir
les primes d'assurance.
CHARLES RABBAT, Intelli-Force
Sécurité et ancientationentation
de 300 %. La prime a triplé.
Puis ça, part
des déductibles qui ont monté
d'à peu près 1000 %.
- Les voleurs sont
de plus en plus actifs.
moins de 5000 vols de voitures
chaque aontréal.ontréal.ontréal.
Mais l'an dernier, ce nombre
a grimpé à plus de 6500.
JESSE CARON,
utomobile, CAA-Québec
- Depuis que le déconfinement
est en place, effectivement,usse
rapide, que ça soit au Québecou.
- À cause de la pandémie,
il y a des raretés sont
beaucoup, beaucoup en demande.
- Les stratagèmes
des voleurs évoluent au gré
de la te de déjouer les clés
intelligentes qui permettent de
démarrer un véhicule en appuyant
sur un bouton, à condition
d'une minute.
- C'est cile. Ça prend
généralement deux malfaiteurs :
un qui se place près de la porte
d'entrée avec un appareil
la clé intelligente qu'on a
laissée près de la porte,
par exemple, et il y a une autre
personne qui est près de(&
appareils-là vonler.ler.ler.ler.
Le signal de la clé intelligente
'appareil
du malfaiteur qui est à côté
de l'auto. Il peut déverrouiller
le véhicule, démarrer le moteuré
victime d'un autre stratagème
beaucoup plus répandu.
Son véhicule a été retrouvé par
un huissstationnement situé
à un kilomètre du parc.
- Lui, il trouvait
qu'il y ait un CRV de stationné
dans le fond du stationnement,
de plaque, puis il avait vu que
c'était e volé, donc,
le huissier a installlé un sabot
de Denver sur notre véhicule
de là, a communiqué avec le 911.
Quand le policier m'a appelé,
"Venez, mais c'est sûr que
vous ne pourrez pavec.vec.vec.v.
Assurément, votre clé ne
fonctionnera plus pour ouvrir
démarrer le véhicule."
- La porte de son Honda CRV
a été forcée et, selon toute
s'est ensuite branché
au port OBD 2, c'ee
à la prise diagnostique située
sous le tableau de bord.
- On va y insérer un petit
iteur à ce moment-là,
avec un ordinateur ou un autre
appareil, d'aller carrément
dans l'ordinateur de commande
intelligente. Donc, c'est
comme si on repartait à zér
et qu'on assignait une nouvelle
clé intelligente au véhicule.
- Les voleurs déplacent ensuite
les véhicules et les laissen
au cas où un système de repérag,
comme ils ont fait avec
la voiture d'Hugo
de se faire pincerpar la police.
- Si personne n'est venu,st enc,
ils embarquent dans le véhicule
et ils s'en vont le porter..s
été marquée, elle va êtrece qu',
chop-chop... des expressions
dans le langage, o au port,
mise dans un container, puis
envoyée à l'extérieur du pays.
de réseaux criminels qui
de Montréal
pour mener leurs activités.
- On a retrouvé des véhicules
avec des plaques volées enau Si,
au Nigeria.
- Le fabricant, tout ce
c'est : "Faites-vous installerè"
Donc, c'est ce qu'on a fait
finalement, mais o de centai des
de dollars supplémentaires.- Ché
de prendre le taureau par
les cornacturier.acturier.actur.
- On a un système chez nous
il est confidentiel, on le garde
oindrement,
un voleur essaye de partir avec
le véhicule avec une fausse
d'alarme déclenche, la voiture,.
- Pour se prémunirplacerplacerpr
sa clé intelligente dansune boîd
on est à la maison. Ça bloque
les ondemplifier.
On peut aussi faire installer
un protecteur d'OBD, un petit
boîtier en métal qui protège
aussi le système
de repérage et la bonne viei
barre antivol qui permet
de verrouiller le volant.de sécr
sera découragé e
de choisir un autre véhicule.